what are you selling here I'm selling my
[ __ ] hey there I'm Aria and we're
here at the avian expose the world's
largest adult convention and I figured
what better way to get the full
experience than to spend a day working
here by running my own booth the little
hiccup I guess is that I am NOT a porn
star and so the only actual merch I have
to sell are these headshots I took when
I was 18 this is the one I submitted for
Glee yeah this is the one submitted for
Gossip Girl I love that show
unfortunately after an hour of no sales
it became clear that nobody was
interested in stopping by my booth okay
I quit too well hear any any tips taking
Kingsley's advice I figured that walking
around would also give me a good
opportunity to learn more about the
convention what are you selling beer
I'm selling my [ __ ] she's not lying
oh my that that is that is what are you
guys doing here at AVM what are we doing
here we're bringing the party
avian is like the Super Bowl of the
avians is it coming together people
celebrating sexuality I think that a lot
of people just think that we're probably
a lot of just trashy drug STD infested
crazy lowlife people and we're actually
thriving and doing quite well and
actually we're really happy because
we're able to express our sexuality so
openly it's more of art like you know
everybody getting together and
appreciating the working and what we do
I love the models I love the fans just
it is a great community to be a part of
I have never felt so much love then I
have this week for me I'm in heaven here
then people come up they talk they want
to know about the industry I want to
tell them about the industry educate
them they're really just business people
that are trying to network with other
business people I'm actually running my
own movie and I want to ask you for your
expertise
sell these headshots my job I'm trying
to sell my own merchandise your ass I
love it man Wow oh my god there's no
taxi you could play like that the hot
younger brother who like seduces the
mill from next door that's very specific
you're a little too nice and this one so
shows that you can get body I'm
wondering how much do you think I should
be charging people for these five
dollars how much you pay you Kelly
you're gonna be more than five five
dollars too if you had like save some
skin maybe ten so there's a lack of skin
on there there's no body so I mean how
much skin should I be having showing you
gotta have to dig guide no no no this is
limited edition I only had 50 of these
Brutus thank God for that I think you
can easily get like a 50 out of it like
that yeah you're being that you know I
just feel like around 40 or 50 headshots
are $5 a pop generally we like to buy
one for 40 or 50 I think that going
average prices
no my hands are $10 at least you
probably may be poor off a desperate $10
10 I would say 10 bucks
I do think you can sell some you believe
me right dude it's all about your
attitude it's all about your personality
and it's all about having confidence you
put yourself out there you make these
people say hey look at me you're good to
go
is there any chance you'd be interested
in buying a headshot of mine for $10 I'm
wondering if you'd be interested in
buying one of my headshots for $10 oh
you're very handsome but you know I have
no need for your headshot or I would
come on I'll do one of a girl man what
imma do with a picture you man I don't
know you do whatever you want little
Knight I don't judge I'm trying to sell
my headshots here if anyone would like
to buy one $10 for a headshot is anyone
interested are they be interested in
buying one for 10 bucks no I think I'm
good on the headshots not to make you no
I'm alright thank you does it make any
difference if I offer I decided for you
not for me it does it but thank you so
much have a great day guys
oh y'all hit this guy's I buy one
all right sure yeah you really about for
10 bucks
oh my god you serious that's amazing
thank you so much try to make it rain
now Brian wha my god Brian is the life
stare which one would you like
I want this I like the side view this
one's like hey what's going on I'm
everybody's best friend so I think the
best friend one you want you are my best
friend for buying this headshot what
compels you to buy this I mean you're
such a likeable guy
it's something we like to support I know
what it's like to kind of promote
yourself I know it's like to go out
there and hustle and market yourself
like we're doing here so much respect to
you because we're doing the same thing
I'm gonna write something inappropriate
on here for you to Brian I hope you
enjoyed this picture late at night
definitely well definitely having some
some type of dreams with this one I've
managed to sell three of them I'm an
axillary confidence take away from this
is that this community is incredibly
supportive of one another and I am very
thankful that they supported me in my
endeavors today so that's it for me here
at ABN and if anyone out there wants to
buy a headshot it hit me up $10 15 with
the signature 15 with a signature she's
got it
jiminee final words might say to your
fans your viewers out there just in
general oh my that is it that is a
tongue